is it hard for you guys to pick sponsors
I know you guys have a new sponsorship
you guys have new sponsorship with Bud
Light right yep but is it do people like
do companies come and do like shark tank
for you kind of to present the brand or
like kind yeah kind of so um you know
the UFC is at a point now where you know
guys come to us and and and want to
pitch their their brands or whatever it
is to to uh advertise with us
and recently you know I I've become very
involved in the uh on the sponsorship
side so you know I I meet with these
guys and and uh you know I just did a an
interview the other day with with the
media at the scrummed slap and it's just
I'm at a point now where in my life in
my career I want to be with people that
I'm aligned with people that you know
yeah it's it's not it's not just about
the money it's like this whole B light
deal you know people are talking [__]
now sell out and all the [__] that that
they'll [__] say believe me I'm the
furthest [__] thing from a sellout
yeah budlight is the right move for me
they're exactly who I want to be with
right now and uh we are very aligned as
far as core values go you know what I
mean 65,000 Americans they employ yeah
that right there should be enough 65,000
Americans are employed there why would
you want to put a bullet in that brand
off of one [__] thing how about you
go back and look at all the good things
they've done yeah right a good point and
where they really stand what they really
believe in they take care of veterans
they they they take care of veterans
families and First Responders families
who have fallen and the list just goes
on and on almost a billion dollars a
year with us Farmers wow that alone is
the reason you should be drinking
[__] Bud Light yeah so [__] I I look
deeper than just [__] you know oh
they did this [__] can with whoever I
don't give a [__] about that
it's they've already they're showing
right now that they're coming with me
and they want to be aligned with me MH
those of you that are hardcores some of
you guys are fanatical on this [__] that
should be your you know you guys think
you're all looking for an apology I
ain't going to [__] apologize to you
yeah [__] that just cuz some risky fella
you know just cuz some you know and they
had 2500 influencers that day they gave
everybody their own can I know they did
I knew that [__] I'm like they just gave
a can everybody nobody's paying
attention if if I don't know where I'm
at sexually I could probably use a drink
you
know that's honestly how I feel dude
that guy's having that guy's having the
toughest day that's [__] you can't
decide what union to [__] be in bro
that's a [__] issue dude that's a big
issue to me but um no I think look man I
think it's important and you know what
it makes me think I don't look and see
who because we're in a place now where I
can choose the advertisers that I want
and I never thought about that before I
never have until just now and I could I
can look at advertisers and see if they
have some of the same beliefs and values
that I do 100% you know and it's
important and that is how you start to
BU build back things the other way I
wish and it makes it fun whoever you are
and whatever you believe in when you
align yourself with people not just the
people that work for you and around you
but the sponsors that you're with it
just makes everything so much more fun
you enjoy your job you love what you do
every day and there's no [__]
nobody's [__] calling you going you
know hey don't have [__] Kennedy on
your show hey go [__] yourself yeah
[__] tell me who I'm going to have on
my show yeah go John F [__] yourself
that's what I'll tell him exct
exactly